the worlds of literature and journalism
are mourning their the loss of writer
Tom Wolfe this morning the author
considered a magician with words died of
an infection Monday in a New York
Hospital he was 88 years old his first
novel the bonfire of the vanities took
his writing to a huge audience Wolfe
satirical flair jumped off the pages as
he shared captivating stories on topics
from hippies to astronauts
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn looks at wolves
rule-breaking style flat good morning
good morning his influence extended
beyond his fellow writers astronaut
scott Kelly tweeted that as a teenager
he was inspired by one of wolfs most
famous books in a statement Wolf's
publisher said the author was blazingly
original with a voice that rang out from
the page to see Tom Wolfe was to
recognize his iconic white suit the
uniform he wore for much of his
professional life to read Tom Wolfe was
to absorb what author William F Buckley
once called probably the most skillful
writer in America a man who can do more
things with words than anyone else with
his words will help define a style of
writing called New Journalism blending
the techniques of a novelist with those
of a reporter as he explained to Jeff
Glor in 2016 that was exciting stuff I
assumed when I first started working for
newspapers well I'd be a novice one day
but I lost total interest in being a
novelist because this nonfiction was so
exciting he would regain that interest
and in 1987 his first novel the bonfire
of the vanities a satirical takedown of
the excesses of the 1980s became a
best-seller and was made into a movie it
was the second of his books to be
adapted to the screen who was the best
pilot I ever saw
you're looking at it the right stuff
detailing the early years of the u.s.
space program was also a best-seller and
an oscar-winning film tremendous I did
find as many astronauts as I as I
couldn't and talked to them and I need
as much reporting as possible cutting
his teeth as a reporter the native
Virginian would write 17 books in all
including scathing critiques of art and
architecture as well as essay
collections works of journalism and four
novels a collection of works as iconic
as the man himself
woofs last work was the kingdom of
speech in 2016 though he had no desire
to slow down he told CBS news in 2016 he
had five more books planned he leaves
behind his wife of 40 years and their
two adult children and guys I was just
writing some of the phrases that have
entered into our lexicon because I'm Tom
Wolfe pushing the envelope Masters of
the Universe social x-rays the me decade
radical chic I loved what the writer
Michael Lewis wrote he said he said what
I hope people know about him is that he
was a sweet and generous man not just a
great writer but a great soul he didn't
just help me become a writer he did it
with pleasure yeah and he made
three-piece white suits look very cool
literary Flair and sartorial Flair hell
Ryan Pedro that our executive producer
three-piece suits are not a bad thing
[Laughter]
thank you